transport il y a du nouveau sur les
lignes n etu du Transilien 12 trains
supplémentaires sont désormais proposés
chaque semaine sur l'axe Paris
Montparnasse Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
Montigny-le-Bretonneux terminus
Rambouillet c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour les usagers avec des temps de
parcours allant de 19 à 21 minutes c'est
un supplémentaire vont leur permettre de
gagner jusqu'à 18 minutes sur leur
trajet c'était ce mardi 26 septembre
l'université Versailles 50 ans les
minorganisé son forum de rentrée à
Guyancourt plus de 45 associations
étaient présentes sur place l'occasion
pour les étudiants de s'inscrire dans
des structures sportives culturelles ou
encore humanitaires les animations
étaient également au programme en sport
le vélodrome national de 50 ans en
Yvelines va accueillir début janvier les
championnats de France de cyclisme sur
piste l'occasion pour le public de voir
en action les futurs pistards français
qui seront présents aux Jeux olympiques
de 2024 Mathilde gros Florian grimbeau
ou encore Marie divine quoi mais seront
présents la billetterie devrait ouvrir
prochainement ce sera la troisième fois
après 2014 et 2019 que le vélodrome
national accueille les championnats de
France